محطة قطار بالقرب من
اللاجئين الحدوديين الأوكرانيين البولنديين
يسحقون كل جزء من الفضاء
طوال حياتهم في أوكرانيا المهجورة
في الوقت الحالي ،
نجد يوليا متعبة تبكي
الأم العزباء التي هربت من وطنها لسبب واحد
كان ابنها البالغ من العمر ست سنوات
محتلاً من قبل مدينتي  جيش روسي
وكنا نعيش من
الجنود ، وكان إطلاق النار
والقصف أمرًا فظيعًا للغاية ، لذا كنت أحاول
إنقاذ
ابني والخروج من
التحسين ، وهي تستيقظ ابنها الروماني ، لقد مرت خمسة
أيام من السفر إلى الجحيم ولكن
وصلت ليوليا وهي مرتاحة  ولكن
مع الشعور بالذنب والدتها عالقة في
أوكرانيا ،
ما زلت لا
أستطيع أن أدرك
كل ما حدث
لأنني تركت وظيفتي شقتي
الخاصة ،
كل شيء تعيشه أمي
في حالة
ضياع وعدم اليقين هو
رفيق دائم للاجئ جديد في بعض الأحيان
الراحة البسيطة هي كل ما في وسعهم  نأمل
أن تحاول بولندا توفير
منشورات تقول أيها الأوكرانيون الأعزاء
إننا في انتظارك على الجانب البولندي
من الحدود ، مرحبًا بكم في بولندا
للآخرين  إعادة عروض الوظائف تقدم العائلات البولندية
غرفًا في
منازلهم ،
لكن بعض اللاجئين يقولون إنه لا
يتم الترحيب بالجميع ومساعدتهم بأذرع مفتوحة ،
فهذه هي شيم شيب بولاند في محطة القطار
ويمكنك أن ترى أنها تتعاون
مع أشخاص هناك
طائرات بدون طيار و  بساتين الأشخاص القادمين
من القطارات لأننا على بعد حوالي 20
دقيقة من أقرب معبر حدودي رئيسي
مع أوكرانيا ، نحن لا
نرى الأوكرانيين الأصليين فقط بل نرى
أشخاصًا مقيمين في أوكرانيا من
جميع
أنحاء العالم.
نحن نرى الكاميرونيين
نرى نيجيريين نشاهدهم نيباليين ،
بعضهم طلاب وكلهم يائسون
لمعرفة شيء واحد في
مكان ما ينامون فيه بسلام
حتى في درجات حرارة أقل من درجة التجمد وهو أمر
لن يحدث لهؤلاء الأشخاص ومعظمهم من
الأفغان والأفغان.  مهاجرون أفريقيون
لأننا من أوكرانيا نحن جميعًا نحتاج إلى مساعدة
نيا لا تريد أن يظهر وجهها خائفًا من
أن انتقاداتها ستجعلها هدفًا
لمزيد من الإساءة لكنها تقول إنها هي
نفسها  جربت وشهدت العنصرية في
اللعب وهي تحاول الفرار من أوكرانيا في قطار مجاني ،
كل الرجال السود لا لا لا
أحد داخل التغيير دخلوا
داخل القطار وأريه مسدسًا
يخرجون وضعوا مسدسًا في وجه رجل أسود
قلت: غادر وخرج
لأنه كان يشعر بالملل نوعًا ما ، لذا فأنت
تخبرني أن هناك تمييزًا من
قبل الأوكرانيين ضد التمييز ضد السود
على الظهر ، حيث يدخل الأشخاص
إلى
القطار القطار المجاني الذي
يساعدون فيه شعبهم الذي لا يريدون
تقول إنه كان الأوكرانيون أولاً
هم الأشخاص الذين تقول إنهم كانوا حتى الآن
دافئين ومرحبين بها وعائلتها
خلال سنواتهم العشر التي عاشوا فيها
هناك نصف مليون لاجئ وفقًا
للأمم المتحدة في طريقهم للخروج من أوكرانيا.
قصة رعب فريدة من نوعها حول كيفية النجاة
من حرب غير مبررة